>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Using
Your Wish List
>> Judy: Hi, I'm Judy Dixon
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover
using your wish list.
From the BARD Express Main
Menu select Wish List.
You will be presented
with a list of the types
of materials you have
downloaded from BARD.
The contents of your wish list can
also be sorted by Subject or Author.
In this example I am going to
select All Books and Magazines.
All of the materials available
on your wish list will present.
>> NVDA: The Writer:
January 2016, 1 of 3.
Nano. Author: Cook, Robin, 2 of 3.
The New Yorker: June 20, 2016.
3 of 3. Download button, Alt plus D.
There is now one item downloading.
Downloads are complete.
Wish list: all books and
magazines, two items.
>> Judy: Once your downloads are
complete your books will be stored
on your BARD Express
bookshelf until you are ready
to transfer them to a cartridge.
See the How-to Transfer Materials to
a cartridge video for instructions.
For additional instructions
on using BARD Express,
see the other videos in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.